So I'm a science policy analyst
at the National Institutes
of Health.
For those of you
that don't know,
the NIH is the largest
funder of biomedical research
in the world.
It consists of 27
different institutes each
each with a different
focus on human health.
I work at one of those
institutes, the National
Institute of Allergy
and Infectious Diseases.
You may, this guy
may look familiar.
You may even own a bobblehead
or a pair of Dr. Fauci socks.
But he's the director of NIAID and
has been for almost the past 40
years.
And NIAID's mission
is to fund research
in infectious diseases,
biodefense and immune
mediated diseases such
as asthma and allergy.
So a little bit about myself.
I was a cancer researcher
for a little
for a little over a decade.
I started at the University
of Arizona Cancer Center,
and then I moved to the
National Cancer Institute
in Bethesda, Maryland.
And I tell you this
because I beg you,
please, no infectious
disease questions.
You'll be disappointed.
But while at the NCI,
I developed a love
for science policy.
I then left the lab and
started a new position
at NIAID and the Data
Analytics and Research Branch.
And there I was
introduced to R
and all of the
tools and packages
that I'll be
talking about today.
So when I joined NIAID, I
joined a very small team
as me and two other
analysts, and I kind of
felt like this is what we do.
This is how I felt the team was.
We were small and
scrappy, but we really
wanted to have an impact on a
large organization like NIAID.
And today, I'm going
to tell you about how
we use Shiny to support NIAID
and make our team a lot more
efficient as well.
So the first example,
I want to give you
is a Shiny dashboard to hit
research funding targets.
So why do we have funding
targets for a specific research
area? First,
we're a government
organization, so Congress
can tell us we'd like you to
spend this amount of money
on this research area so it can
be congressionally mandated.
We also sometimes
receive targeted funding
aside from the NIH budget.
One example of this recently
was Operation Warp Speed
for COVID vaccine development.
And finally, NIAID
leadership can also
set funding goals based on
NIAID's mission and priorities
at the time.
But when I first got
involved in this process,
I found out it was a lot more
complex than I originally
imagined.
So in some research areas
that we're tracking,
there are over 700
different projects.
These are grants
and contracts that
represent a lot of
different moving parts.
To give you an idea,
in some of these areas,
we're tracking over half a
billion dollars worth of funding.
And another added
layer of complexity
is that at NIH, we
receive grant applications
throughout the year.
So we're stuck making
important funding decisions
at the beginning
of the year when
we don't have all of the
data available to us,
so we don't have
all of the grants
that we're going
to fund that year.
But I wanted to use
an analogy to help
understand this process.
So you can imagine that hitting
these research funding targets
are sort of like a road trip, right?
So on a road trip,
you have to know
exactly where you are
at any given point
and how you're going to
get to your destination.
Otherwise, you're
going to get lost.
But we all know
it's not that easy.
Sometimes things
come along that make
it difficult to get
where you want to go.
I'm thinking of
one specific road
trip I took moving from
Tucson to Bethesda, Maryland.
On this road trip,
I got a flat tire.
My air conditioning broke in
the middle of a heat wave,
and I had a very vocal,
very disgruntled cat
in the back seat
for 2,300 miles.
But today, I want to
talk about the challenges
that we faced, hitting these
research funding targets
and how we use Shiny to
address those challenges.
So first, like I said, there's
a lot of different moving parts.
There's a lot of people
involved in this process
throughout the Institute.
I immediately found
out that there
were a lot of competing
estimates, right?
Everybody had their own
idea of where we were.
So it's like, if
you're on a road trip
and you know you're in
Dallas, somebody else
thinks you're in El Paso
and another person thinks
that you're in Utah, and nobody
can agree on where you are,
where you're at the moment.
So it was really frustrating.
Even worse is when people
would come to me with funding
estimates and have no details.
So it's like somebody saying,
we're in Missouri and I'm like,
there's no chance
we're in Missouri.
You took a wrong exit somewhere.
How did you get there?
And they would have no idea.
So my team spent a
lot of time and effort
trying to figure out how
they came to that conclusion
and comparing it to
our estimate, too.
And finally, at the beginning
of this process, a lot of people
were, you know, reliant on
spreadsheets and emails.
And this is a big
problem because you
can imagine that immediately,
once you send that email,
that information is out of date
because at NIH we're constantly
getting new
applications and making
new awards throughout the year.
So, and also people
make mistakes, right?
When you're
searching your inbox,
maybe you found that email
from last week or last month.
So it was hard to get
everybody on the same page.
So I created the research
area tracking tool
to help address these questions.
But how does this dashboard get
us closer to our destination?
First, behind the scenes, I
have an R Markdown document
that's pulling in data from
multiple different databases.
I use dbplyr, so I never have
to look at SQL coding again.
And so it transforms
it, formats it,
and writes it to a database
for our Shiny dashboard to use.
And because I published
it on RStudio Connect,
I can schedule it to run daily
so that the information is
always up to date.
So we've immediately made this
process a lot better, right?
So we have data integration,
multiple data sources
in one spot.
The information is
always up to date
and people have one source that
they can go to for information.
Kind of like a
Google maps, right?
So next, I want to
address this problem
of having multiple estimates.
And it seemed like everybody,
people around the Institute
had little pieces
of the puzzle,
but we could never put those
together and get the big
picture, so in the dashboard, I
made all of the data available.
So every single--you can see
every single project
that's included or not
included in our estimate.
So this is almost like having
turn by turn directions showing
you exactly where we are and how
we're going to get to our goal.
We've made this data
available to be downloaded
at any point for any user.
We also wanted this to be a
platform for collaboration.
So you can add and remove
projects from the estimate
as well.
This is an example of that
where you can add a project
and add a reason
for that change
so that other users can see
why you made that change.
And so that the data
is always up to date,
the Shiny dashboard writes
all of these user inputs
to a database.
So that whenever a user logs
on, it's always up to date
and includes all of those
user inputs as well.
So the benefit of this is that
we've increased transparency
and collaboration in
this whole process
and hopefully we've gotten
closer to our destination.
So lastly, I wanted
the dashboard
to be able to make predictions
based on an application score.
So at NIH, when an
application comes in,
it's basically reviewed by
an expert panel of scientists
and they give it a score
that helps us determine
whether we fund it or not.
So this dashboard can
actually make predictions
on how much we're going
to fund even before we've
made those awards.
And since this dashboard is
based on Shiny reactivity,
all of the graphs, the tables,
the high level numbers,
everything can be changed
based on user input.
So we've allowed users to adjust
that scoring cutoff as well.
So if you're in a
meeting saying
"I want to fund all of the
applications up to this score,"
you can actually change
that in the dashboard
and see how it affects
the estimates so
that you can make these
important decisions
in real time.
So I hope that
this dashboard has
made this process a lot easier
and maybe a little bit more
accurate as well.
But I think in the end, my
small team benefited the most.
Right, because we've
been able to automate
a lot of these processes
and really free us up
to take on additional projects,
right? Before, we were
spending so much time
manually updating the
data, answering questions
from colleagues
and making changes
that we didn't have that
much time to do other things.
So the next example
I want to give you
is how we've used
machine learning
to classify NIAID grants.
So just a little
background on grants
At NIH, there are
really two main types.
One starts at NIH.
So we send out a request
for applications.
And this is when the NIH
asks the scientific community
to apply for funding in a very
specific, well-defined area.
We usually use these
to stimulate research
in really high priority areas.
The next type of application
is the investigator-
initiated application.
So instead of
starting at NIH, we're
starting with that
investigator or scientist
that's running a lab somewhere, right?
So these make
up by far the majority
of our applications, greater
than 85%, And so at NIH,
we really have to rely on
the scientific community,
the creativity and ingenuity
that they have to come up
with innovative research ideas.
And those ideas can be very
broad and cross-cutting or very
narrow and well defined.
But when we get
those applications,
these investigator-
initiated ones,
we don't have much
information on it.
Besides that, it falls
in the broad research
areas of NIAID's mission.
So you can imagine that this
is very difficult, right?
When you're dealing with
thousands of applications,
how do we know how
much we've funded
and what projects we funded
in a specific research area?
So we get questions
all the time.
How much have you spent
on HIV vaccine research
or, you know, how much have you
spent on tuberculosis research
and what projects?
And we need to be able to
answer those questions.
So how do we do that?
The answer is we have a team.
We have a team for that.
So every year, NIAID gets
over 9,000 grant applications
and we fund about 20%
of these, give or take.
We then have a team
of about 3 to 6 people
that go through
these awarded grants
and apply codes based on
the research being proposed.
So they have 1,300 unique
codes, over 1,300 unique codes
that they can use to
describe that research.
And I've included a few
examples here on the right.
So they look, are they
researching a specific disease
like Ebola or Zika?
Is the research area, you know,
new therapeutics or diagnostics,
and so on.
But you can imagine with
thousands of grants,
this can be challenging.
First, it's very time intensive.
So they have to go
through thousands
of these awarded grants and
read the title, the abstract,
the specific aims, and
describe that research.
Because it's so time-consuming,
we only have the resources
to code awarded grants,
the 80% of applications
that are unfunded we don't
have any information on.
And they have a constantly
increasing workload.
So every year we're
getting more applications
and giving out more awards.
And especially at the
beginning of the pandemic,
this was--we saw a huge
increase in applications
due to COVID research.
And finally, because
it takes so much time,
this usually isn't done until
the very end of the year.
So we don't have real
time data on this,
which would be helpful.
So we thought this was
a great opportunity
to use supervised
machine learning
for grant classification.
We had a database of
thousands of grants
that had been manually
coded over the past decade
that we could use to train
machine learning models.
So here's an example
of a grant that's
proposing to research a
more sensitive diagnostic
for tuberculosis.
When I looked up the
codes on this grant,
you could see the
disease was tuberculosis,
the research area
was diagnostics,
and it was a clinically
focused grant.
So I just want to give you
one example of how we've
used machine learning
to classify grants
based on their research area.
So here it was diagnostics.
But there are five
categories, including
therapeutic, prevention,
and vaccine.
So we took about 7,500 grants
that have been previously
been manually coded
and use them to train
three different machine
learning models, including
logistic regression,
support vector machine,
and random forest
to compare the three.
We then tested these models
using about 3,200 grants that
had also been manually coded.
And so what we found was
the logistic regression
was the most accurate, 88.5%,
and it also did the best
at predicting this relatively
small category of grants
in the prevention class.
So we use this machine, this
logistic regression model,
to build a Shiny dashboard
for coding NIAID grants.
And we then expanded
it to assist in coding
in five additional categories.
So behind the
scenes, once again,
we have an R Markdown document
that's pulling in the data
from multiple sources,
making those machine learning
predictions and writing
this data to a database.
It's constantly getting
updated with new applications,
new awards, and this is
what our Shiny dashboard uses.
And we once again,
we wanted people to
be able to collaborate.
So it's writing user inputs
and a database for future use.
So here's an example of
how we're using those.
We're incorporating
user feedback.
So you can actually go
through each project
and say whether
it's relevant or not
relevant to that specific
area where we're including
the machine learning score.
So they know the probability
that project is in that area.
And once again,
we wanted it to be
a platform for collaboration.
So you can attach notes
to each of these projects
for other users or even
yourself in the future.
Here's an example of that.
You see a tiny little
envelope when a note
is attached to your project.
We also have tags involved.
So if you don't want
to write a whole note,
you can just add a
small tag or phrase.
For example, if somebody
has verified that project,
you can just quickly add that.
So we're hoping
that this project
will improve productivity.
So if previously it took
5 minutes to code a grant,
we're hoping with a
machine learning prediction
and a probability estimate
that we can cut that time down.
And even if it was
one to 2 minutes,
you could imagine
that with thousands
of grants, that's a very
significant time savings.
We also want to support
data driven decision making.
So as I mentioned, 80%
of our applications
are unfunded and
therefore not coded.
But with these machine
learning predictions,
we can apply these codes
to all grant applications
and hopefully we
can identify gaps
where researchers
aren't applying
and we can then
address those gaps.
So I want to thank my small
team for introducing me
to R and all of the
tools and packages
that I've shown you today.
I think we've definitely been
able to have an outsized impact
for such a small team.
And, you know, I hope we can use
the lessons that we've learned
and the tools that
we've developed
to continue to support
NIAID in the future
with their goal of, you know,
to better understand, treat
and ultimately prevent
infectious diseases
and to improve human health.
So thank you.